[Music]
hello it is just after 10 gmt let's
begin with the worsening situation in
afghanistan the united nations human
rights chief has accused the taliban of
serious violations michelle bachelet
says there are credible reports of
summary executions of civilians bachelet
has urged the armed group to commit to
the rights of women and ethnic and
religious minorities she's also called
on the un human rights council to
closely monitor the taliban's actions
we have also received credible reports
of serious violation of international
humanitarian law and human rights abuses
taking place in many areas under
effective taliban control
they include among others
summary executions of civilians and all
the combat members of the afghan
national security forces
restrictions on the right of women
including the right to move around
freely and girls right to attend school
afghanistan's diverse ethnic and
religious minorities are also at risk of
violence and repression
are the leaders of the g7 nations are
scheduled to hold a virtual meeting to
discuss the crisis later on tuesday
under pressure from allies u.s president
joe biden expected to decide on whether
to keep american troops in kabul beyond
the august 31st deadline but the taliban
has warned against any extension of that
date
on the ground more people are continuing
to show up at kabul airport hoping to
get out
well charles stratford is in kabul with
the latest on the evacuation efforts
there nadine baba is in london to tell
us about that uh critical g7 meeting uh
but first let's go live to natasha
butler who is in uh paris for us so uh
natasha we heard some very strong words
at that
meeting in geneva of the unhcr didn't we
yes we heard
from the high commissioner for human
rights at this special session of the
un's human rights council
in geneva an emergency session called to
really focus on the human rights
situation in afghanistan as i said
opening speech by michelle
bachelet and she painted a very grim
picture indeed of the human rights
situation in afghanistan she said that
her office has been inundated in the
past days and weeks
with reports of human rights
abuses she says that outside for example
of the capital kabul in some of the
remote areas girls are being told that
they can't go to school women are being
forced to stay at home she talked about
human rights defenders scared for their
lives trying to flee so an incredibly
grim picture was painted by michelle
bachelet who said that the human rights
council would call on the taliban to
adhere to international rules
international
law to uphold the rights of people in
afghanistan women girls minorities
activists people who've worked in the
past for the media
or for the former government she also
said that all violence must stop on all
sides we also heard during this uh
council session that began a few hours
ago in geneva from uh afghan delegates
the former afghan ambassador to the un
giving a very impassioned speech talking
about the situations there's urging the
international community to act not to
turn away to actually
put into place real actions on the
ground not just words because the
situation is so serious not just now but
will continue to be so in the future
a humanitarian crisis is unfolding as we
speak
the people of afghanistan in particular
the thousands of human rights defenders
journalists academics professionals
civil society members and former
security personnel
who were the backbone
and we hope still will be of a
contemporary and democratic society and
whose lives and livelihoods are at risk
they deserve your full support here at
this council
at least your moral support
to be frank with you you are failing
them
but now today not next month not next
march you have the chance to redeem
yourselves
please take it
please ensure the session has a credible
and strong outcome
please do not leave this tomorrow or the
next month
money i speak to you in afghanistan
already fair that may not they may not
have a tomorrow
in our worst moments we call on you to
do better
well delegates at the human rights
council are expected to adopt a
resolution at the end
of their meeting but what
some of the delegates particularly those
two afghan speakers that you heard there
have been pushing for is a fact-finding
mission a u.n fact-finding mission which
would mean uh that u.n workers would be
deployed in afghanistan to document any
abuses and hold those responsible uh
accountable it is something that
international organizations including
human rights watch have been calling for
over the past few days we'll have to
wait and see whether or not that is part
of the final resolution
natasha thank you let's turn now to uh
the latest developments inside
afghanistan now charles stratford is
live for us in kabul and charles the
taliban government slowly taking shape
now we're hearing of some new
appointments
well i think it's early to say um that
the taliban government is taking shape
it's very important to to to note that
this information is being put out by
reuters and they're quoting a news
agency called pagewalker a local news
agency and these appointments we
understand are acting appointments they
in no way reflect any um
at this stage potential future
government
but according to the patchwork news
agency quoted by reuters the taliban
have
uh appointed a new acting finance
minister a man called gul agar
he is a what we understand was a famous
military commander in helmand province
it's also being reported that the
taliban have appointed an acting
interior minister a man called sadhara
ibrahim again a famous commander who
we've been told was very close to the
former taliban leader
and
the acting intelligence chief apparently
has also been appointed
a man called najibullah who at this
stage we are making calls to confirm
whether
these appointments have have indeed been
made and to get more information
certainly about that
what's being reported as the acting
intelligence chief
it's obviously important to recognize
that the taliban have been in
consultations with the former president
here mohammed karzai and the former
chief negotiator on behalf of ashraf
ghani abdullah abdullah in recent days
to try and flesh out the beginnings of
negotiations for a formal government a
formal administration we understand that
those negotiations are ongoing
but when you speak to analysts here the
fundamental concerns that they have
along with human rights abuses and rule
of law are also financial ones and
it's interesting that an acting finance
minister has reportedly been appointed
today because there are real concerns
about whether the taliban have the
experience to run this country and to
deal with the very great sort of
financial needs and challenges that it
faces
a lot of discussion charles about the uh
ongoing evacuations there's that g7
meeting coming up later today uh and and
whether they will extend the deadline of
of august 31st for the us to to get out
completely what's the latest we're
hearing about the situation in in kabul
airport right now
well the evacuations continue um the
americans yesterday saying it was the
the greatest number of people have been
evacuated in one day yesterday um
they're also saying that up to 200
planes are being are involved in this
effort and as you say we're getting
closer by the day
towards the august 31st deadline we know
there is pressure on biden we understand
there is increasing pressure by
other nato members um that kind of
pressure which we are expecting to see
at this g7 summit later the taliban as
we know have called august the 31st a
red line and they have warned of
consequences but let's
remind ourselves that this deadline for
the withdrawal of the us nato forces
from this country has already been
changed twice and the taliban are
looking for some sort of international
legitimacy here despite their rhetoric
of saying this is being a red line and
threatening consequences
it remains to be seen as to how forceful
they would be when they are trying to be
taken very seriously as they say by
members of the international community
and they are in such dire need of money
and money that remains locked up the u.s
having frozen around 9 billion in u.s
accounts and that's afghan cash
charles stratford in kabul thank you
well spain is warning it will have to
leave people behind in afghanistan while
germany's foreign minister has suggested
it may take longer to get people out
beyond the end of august it is the first
nato country to publicly say
it is in talks to keep kabul airport
open for evacuations into september
since we filmed it
we are in talks with the us and turkey
in order to keep kabul airport
operational to make civil evacuations of
these people possible we will have a
role to keep discussing that with the
taliban and doing so because they will
have to play a special role in that
well let's talk now to nadim barber who
is live in london for us so nadeem looks
like the g7 leaders are divided on that
extension of the deadline what's likely
to happen
well has in this virtual g7 meeting of
the leaders of uh
industrialized nations that's the us the
uk canada france germany italy and japan
uh a meeting under the chairmanship of
prime minister boris johnson but it's
also attended virtually by the nato
secretary general jens stoltenberg and
the united nations secretary general
antonio guterres
beyond what happens right now in terms
of evacuations there are big questions
that they're expected to talk about the
first is uh if and when to recognize the
new taliban administration in kabul
the 2020
agreement signed by the trump
administration
actually explicitly states that the
taliban is not recognized by the united
states
as a state beyond that there are
questions of whether in fact there
should be renewed sanctions on the
taliban to pressure them to
commit to their human rights commitments
we've been hearing what the u.n human
rights chief has been saying about
violations reports of violations coming
in already so whether to try to pressure
them to
step up and meet those commitments and
also commitments on international
relations but in the short term yes
there is pressure on president biden the
uk would like to keep its 1 000 or so
military personnel in kabul keep the
airlifts going they would like a few
more days beyond the deadline of next
tuesday but ben wallace the uk defense
minister in the last few hours has said
that is unlikely and that the uk will
not be able to do anything if the us
does withdraw on that deadline um the uh
shadow foreign secretary of the uh
opposition labour party here in the uk
is urging boris johnson not just to come
up with a plan not just to push
president biden on airlifts but for a
longer term plan including to help
countries such as pakistan which have
already received millions of afghan
refugees over the years and expected to
receive more in the near future she says
that boris johnson can play a leadership
role in trying to get the g7 nations to
try to agree some sort of assistance
plan for the
region nadeem baba thank you
the taliban insists it will allow
civilians to leave afghanistan even
after foreign forces withdraw but many
afghans are skeptical and continue to
arrive at kabul airport hoping to get
out charlotte bellis reports from there
thousands of people at kabul airport
going nowhere
beyond the gate are planes that us
president biden promised would take them
away but it's shut so they jostle for
position the criteria who is most
threatened by the taliban
my mother has been inside the airport
for the last six days but the rest of
our family stuck outside because of all
the people at the gate
this is the north gate where most people
are asked to enter through but in recent
days it has been closed because of what
the us says is security threats from
isil but for most people here the
biggest threat is a stampede is
dehydration and gunfire
more than 20 people have been killed in
the last week in and around the airport
i'm living here with my children right
now i'm scared of the crowd and all the
gunfire there's no information the us
shouldn't have announced anything if
they weren't able to take people out
on the road to the north gate this is
where the taliban presence ends and
afghan special forces begin specifically
nds-0 units the two are separated by a
piece of string
the zero units ban filming so we record
on our phones all other afghan security
forces surrendered but they did not
zero units are funded by the cia and
accused of night raids and human rights
abuses
there is a lot of danger here the nds
zero units they're doing a lot of firing
they threaten people a lot of people are
wounded
the u.s put them in charge of this
stretch of road to separate western
forces from the taliban still as we
filmed the taliban drove past unhindered
at the airport gunfire has been the main
cause of injuries these were the zero
units last week shooting appears to be
their preferred method of crowd control
the taliban has also moved in some of
its most feared fighters the badri 313
it is a special forces wing associated
with the powerful haqqani network they
are now securing the perimeter of the
airport
people are trying to reach evacuation
flights because they say they are scared
of the taliban yet it's the taliban they
must get through first followed by zero
units in a lawless stretch of land the
u.s says it is flying out tens of
thousands of people for their protection
but first making them cross a dangerous
road to safety charlotte bellas al
jazeera